Molecular clouds are the birthplace of stars and planets
but how these diaphanous fogs of gas collapse
into burning balls of hydrogen is not well understood.
Part of the problem is that the exact shape
and structure of the clouds is hard to discern
since we only see them from one point of view.
Researchers have now found a new way to reveal
such structures by finding a molecular cloud
that is ringing like a bell.
The team observed Musca, a molecular cloud
about 570 light-years from Earth that appears
as an elongated filament, using
Europe’s Herschel Space Telescope.
Around the denser filament there appear to be
striations in the gas that astronomers have suspected
might be caused by waves
propagating through the cloud.
By analyzing the spacing of the striations,
researchers showed that they are caused by
oscillations of the cloud at resonant frequencies,
known as normal modes.
By modelling such modes in clouds of various shapes
they found that Musca is not a filament, but a sheet
but a sheet, viewed edge-on,
and could calculate its size.
The team hopes that this technique could be
used to study many other clouds
and so shed light on how these
stellar nurseries produce their young.